yes we are away talia cervantes after a
big victory
in her game
talia tell us about this game
um well thank you for having me here i i
think overall the game was well
i think i made some strategical good
choices like in the sense of which
pieces i traded
then it got
a little messy um all right
which move which move number do you feel
we should go to it seemed like around
here you were just dominating right it
did look really good and i thought that
i did good at trading and playing rook
d7 yes uh to be honest i missed
queen h5 so
the idea of queen h5 and that they that
she could have like a discover
threat but regardless i think my
position is statically good because of
the pawn structure and the fact that i
control the d file
it did get a little messy but i don't
think she ever had anything
overall i thought it was
quite
well
right and i think
here
um i thought that i had messed it up
after queen d7
but i'm hoping that rook f7
was good enough or maybe it wasn't oops
the bar is getting up and down tell you
like the issues are pretty harsh like a
pogo stick yeah but here for sure no now
you're really in the driver's seat right
this i thought i could win
relatively easy but i did have to play
until the end so no by now you're
definitely winning
and you were able to pull it off you are
at plus one two draws in a win right is
this your best result so far in three
rounds of the u.s women's championship
well
my only other u.s women's championship
was last year which was online
and
yeah i definitely i can't remember what
was my score but definitely wasn't plus
one so i'm very happy with how it's
going so far you came into this
tournament expecting what
nothing really
um i have been very busy i just started
college so i'm a freshman and i have a
lot of stuff to do
i was just hoping to play as best as i
could and see how i play against
um players that i have watched from the
broadcast like in years prior in this
tournament so
you got any fans at home watching this
um i got a few friends on campus that uh
actually one of them texted me today
like you're in the u.s championship
in my family of course yeah yeah all
right well good showing today for sure
you're tied for first good luck in the
rest of your game thank you quick
question uh tell ya i mean
not to rub any sore point uh your game
with carissa yeah we thought you were
playing a really a great game and
probably after the game you it came to
your mind that you had played a really
good game at the end
you did give her a draw you allowed the
repetition is it because you didn't see
the move rook b3 if you
um originally i wanted to play rook to
c3 which was protecting the bishop
bishop on c2 right i didn't feel like
moving the bishop because then i could
get in somehow but i did see rook c3 i
was concerned about e4 and after i got
back to my room i realized that there
was like this one really nice knight e6
yeah and things are fine for me yeah but
i didn't see it during the game so i
thought that
making a draw would be the best choice
i mean i'm not i'm not mad at the game i
thought that overall i played really
well i we do
and
i don't know it was like a like a
good showing on my part that gave me
confidence for my upcoming rounds right
but it also feels doesn't feel a little
bit like the one that got away
it does yeah uh she played really well
also like she defended really nicely
true um
all right yeah overall i thought it was
like a fine game rally could have been
better but i thought it was okay
well congratulations on your win today
and keep playing good thank you all
right